here at kapow comic convention with
jonathan ross Jonathan what you've been
doing here today well today I've been i
did a panel early one we were talking
about the new book i'm doing me Bryan
Hitch who's just left you've just missed
him and also just comics Emily about my
love of comics and the nature comics and
we were talking to people about writing
comics and that kind of stuff then I
just had a long signing which was very
long yes and I was doing a bit of
wrestling but we've stopped that now
because there's someone got hurt we
shouldn't laugh whatever they'll be okay
by defeated el stupido in the wing
yesterday because he was bad-mouthing
the comic book community and I won't
stand for that so if you've done a bit
of lucenzo before even an unmixed with a
luchador oh well I know these rest of
guys i knows i've been to see them a lot
of time and i went down with a little
bit of training just so I didn't break
everything when I was in the ring I'm
trying to get a show off the ground for
channel 4 so fingers crossed oh cool i
look forward to seeing that nonetheless
it tell us a little bit more about the
comic as well because it's America's Got
powers which I did to love I will
probably well it was a kind of I came up
that day because I was just watching TV
and thinking if we had two beers in the
real world they'd probably be on a
reality show like that and then we
worked out the weaker maybe user to say
something else something different
something about the nature of fighting
and the nature of conflict and the
nature of violent entertainment really
maybe that sounds a bit grant so we're
kind of working on that now book tues
out I've got one copy up is down the
shops next week and then book 3 brian is
drawing as we speak and I'm writing book
for so hopefully by the end of the
summer either finished all of the six
books and he'll be nearly finished this
is kind of a dream for you I know
obviously a huge comic fan aren't you to
be actually writing comic but it's sort
of a dream without really well to keep
my dream was to draw them and I'm not
quite good enough so well I say not
quite I'm not quite by a long way but it
is sort of a dream view item it's great
fun it's just great fun to be partly I
like being part of the community because
i always have felt partly I mean that's
the nice thing about when you're kind of
convention you all feel part of it you
know whether there was a fan or as a
professional I'm kind of in the semi-pro
range i think at the moment but i feel
very much part of it it's just it's nice
to be involved what's it like been
working with brian obviously using an
artist on so many huge title 17 it's
great i mean i try not to think about
the big toes and i want to kind of get
nervous about it but I mean he's so such
a lovely guy to work with anyone also
brilliant artist when the pages come
back and they're always so much better
than you thought there would be or so
much better than you'd imagine them and
I've got a pretty good imagination so
it's a fill so what can we expect now as
the title continues well I just hope to
finish it so it makes sense basically
and I think he does book 3 i'm very
pleased with South Brian and going
forward you know it's that kind of
balancing that between keeping the
overall story moving but making each
issue exciting its own way hopefully so
it's kind of tough but it's great fun
and after that we're probably into
another thing together i'm working with
them Tommy Lee able to the turf with and
he's part way through another series
i've written called Golden Age he's
finished book one and we're working at
that will hopefully be out this year and
I'm working with David la Fuente the
Spanish artist on something and I'm also
worked with ian churchill on another
book which i wrote most of that year ago
so i'm going to rewrite and we're going
to hopefully kick that off early in each
year a lot of the things are you working
on see what you did here for today is
america's got superpowers but a lot of
things you were constant i'm very kind
of cinematic ideas behind them you know
the things i could really imagine as a
TV series or film or video game is that
something you'd like to explore well
people are talking just about various
things but you know what I'd love to am
very happy to be William I'm doing this
because I like comics that's it you know
and I'm not someone who's write anything
I'm going to write this a comic and hope
it gets made into a film you know
someone making a film sure you'd be
lovely but it's not a big deal it's not
what we're looking to do I think comic
should be valued for themselves you know
and that's why we're doing it i love i
love reading comics and i'm very lucky
to be able to write them a moment i love
doing that so it's an end in itself and
if you were this cosplay contest here
says and if you had to dress up in one
costume until the end of time what would
it be till the end of time only one
costume you can have you have to make a
decision okay there'll be a new
character called pajama and kashmir robe
man ok very comfortable it's not too
formal so forgiving that's my outfit and
what would his powers babe his powers
would be to lounge
yeah I love it excellent but is there
gonna be a comic book abide thank very
much doubt it thanks John of it's a
great to speak to you guys thank you
you